hot breath he's he asks um do you have
any advice on how to go from a one-liner
comedian
to longer form bits while still keeping
the quick hard punches
yeah right great question so one you
know
if you take a look at brian kiley uh
brian kiley is
conan o'brien's head monologue writer he
he is
a he is a mechanical just like comedic
mechanics
you know down to the t right he
has found a way to sort of make the make
the flow
of the material sound like it's almost a
complete story so it rolls very nicely
even though they're individual jokes now
the key is i think you can take a story
or concept so i'll start like one and
two liners
uh sometimes and then it'll evolve into
a story a whole story about
um my relationships my failed
relationships and then
but within the story all of the lines
every sentence gives you an opportunity
for a joke right so
um like when i first do a joke about uh
meeting my wife for the first time i'd
do a quick joke about that that could be
done
but then like if i say um my wife
uh it was my wife's birthday the other
day and for her birthday i got her a
gift certificate for his and her
massage and she said jerry this is a
wii gift not a me gift
so i returned it and got her a gift
certificate for dinner for one
and then you know then i can just talk
more about my wife you know my wife
my wife and i we've been married about
15 years and
all of this now the steam is running
along and there could be individual
jokes weaved together with tag stoppers
and act outs
and that's what makes it feel like it's
now a story or a bit
you'll notice that most of the best
comics you know
even sometimes the one two liners um
they'll get up there and they'll do an
act out and knock down just shows up as
an organic piece of the joke so we don't
think about it as an act out
and they'll get into an act out you
watch them on a tv set they'll get into
that act out within the first 30 seconds
and that makes the audience feel like
it's a whole story so there once they
see that act out once they imagine this
in the scenario you just set up with the
act out
you've got them compelled they're seeing
your sitcom
that you're shooting and showing them
right there in front of their face by
acting it out
because they have that suspension of
disbelief sort of like we have in
theater
you know we know the guy's not at a
stream right now but he's splashing his
face with water that's not not there but
we buy it
because it's a it's a play and we
suspend our disbelief same thing happens
in stand-up
when you do an act out all of a sudden
the audience is seeing the pictures
that you're creating and they're in your
story so it could be
one joke but done with an act out it
just really helps that joke evolve into
a bit
yes yeah and that yeah that's great too
to
people to understand a lot of times
these longer bits were actually
smaller individual bits that evolved
over time
and kind of you found themes to tie them
so they seem like it's one long story
but it was a bunch of individual jokes
that just kind of organically formed
into one yeah
and it's an application of the structure
right so if you say okay you say the
joke and you go okay well if this is
true what else is true
mm-hmm and then you could tap and so if
this happened
what would that look like there's the
act down right yeah so then
you can say um you know uh what's my
what is
what are the you know who what where why
when and how what's
the contrasting perspective what is that
well some people think this i think this
and now you're evolving it even more so
you're just taking it
and using your your your ideas and your
techniques
definitely the maximum of the five w's
is one of your best assets
who what where why when and how who who
what who me
who who else is involved who else would
this impact
you know uh who would hate this who
would really like this
you know who would think this was stupid
you know that girl right there oh that's
stupid you know she's you know this
so then how would you respond if she
insulted you or he insulted you
you know now you have a benign
retaliation possibility so
that who what where why went out and how
can really take that story and evolve it
um